les supporters sont prêts jour j pour la
grande famille du sart en voirie
handball plus petit budget du
championnat les joueurs touchent en
moyenne entre 3000 et 3500 euros brut
par mois
l'essentiel n'est pas forcément là
aujourd'hui par rapport au salaire moyen
des français on est pas mal on est on
est plutôt des privilégiés donc il faut
en profiter
alors certes on ne peut pas encore
s'acheter des ferrari mais bon ça sent
n'y a pas de place pour les enfants
les enfants seront dans les gradins en
attendant ce sont les bénévoles qui sont
à pied d'oeuvre
une cinquantaine environ par match
michel est un fidèle depuis la création
du club en 1974 il supervise
l'installation du salon vip
tout doit être terminé à 18h30 j'ai posé
des congés j'ai un patron compréhensif
qui sait que quand on joue à domicile de
mercredi je suis là parce que c'est un
plaisir c'est même si malheureusement à
partir du moment où on fait partie des
bénévoles on voit pas forcément tous les
matches si vous passez un petit moment
avec nous vous allez voir que on est
tous une famille on sens et ça c'est
important
17 heures les joueurs se retrouvent dans
un restaurant partenaire pour la
traditionnelle collation entrée
progressive dans le match avec la séance
vidéo rester concentré pour être fin
prêt à 20h sur les battures recul ans
est mort action débattu en avançant on
aura le temps peut-être de le repousser
un peu il faut se lâcher il faut tout
donner
on verra bien comment ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rencontre se joue à guichet fermé
joueurs famille collègues et amis se
font entendre
même quand c'est difficile ne rien
lâcher
[Applaudissements]
vraiment croire à ça vraiment croire un
autre projet défensif on n'y trouve que
des séquences de défense correcte et on
fait une petite boulette
ça fout tout en l'air aller de l'avant
ne jamais s'avouer vaincu en ce que par
tout son public le saran loiret handball
se bat jusqu'au bout
la défaite est toujours frustrante mais
il faut continuer l'image qu'on renvoie
la combativité le fait d'être un groupe
soudé qui lâche pas ça c'est notre
marque de fabrique est temps que moi je
dirige cette équipe effectivement cds
sont des valeurs qui sont très
importantes pour nous est donc certain
que ça fait ça fait quelque chose quand
on sent que là toute la salle d'eau
depuis nous nous pousse se soulève et on
aurait aimé les faire exploser de joie
la fable du temps et des sourires pour
les supporters les bénévoles et les
partenaires ici c'est ça rend sa rechute